we do see a little bit of heavier  traffic on the south 15 out of the  spaghetti bowl but i think a lot of  folks are taking the day off making it a  four-day holiday weekend and speaking of  that a heads up not just here around the  speedway bowl where the eastbound side  of the northern 215 beltway slows down a  bit all the ramps are open but this is  for folks heading out of town up to uh  whatever st george cedar city duck creek  if you're on the north 15 past the 93  heading towards mesquite you may have  already seen this but if you haven't be  prepared you're down to just one lane  here the freeway sign up here says  you're about 10 miles away from mesquite  with just one lane especially with truck  traffic got an advisory from our friend  justin hopkins over at the nevada  department of transportation saying hey  if you can leave before nine that's  great if you can travel after five  because in between this may turn into a  parking lot